no I'm not gonna do it nobody else can
measure up
[Applause]
[Music]
so patreon sponsored review for this one
and because otherwise I wouldn't really
have occasion to be talking about a film
as old as Star Trek - the Wrath of Khan
this was actually I was really delighted
to have a reason to go back to this it's
funny partly because of just in general
there being so much stuff out there that
I'm either trying to catch up on or new
stuff that I want to see in addition to
stuff that you know I want to give
videos out of it and then you know this
full-time job something resembling life
etc I don't have time to revisit a heck
of a lot of stuff really it's pretty
much just like if I'm introducing
somebody else to it like so like
recently I've gotten to re-watch stuff
because I'm introducing my partner Liz
just some stuff that she hasn't seen
before but something like Wrath of Khan
High God it's gotta be oh heck it might
be over 20 years since the last time I
saw this movie and I did like it but
it's never been my favorite Star Trek
that's not me saying it's not a great
Star Trek I do think that it is a
totally valid argument you know people
who want argue it's the best Star Trek
film for me though I think it just has
to do with it
deviating from like what Star Trek is in
my mind
so like Star Trek for me growing up was
primarily two things it was the next
generation TV show and it was Star Trek
for the voyage home which was the only
Star Trek film that I owned and so I
watched him rewatched Emory watch that
so you know Wrath of Khan is quite
different from that but let's talk about
it cuz I got to rewatch it again first
time in a long time so boy where do we
even start
still looks pretty good honestly I mean
like that the effects are dated but now
they're solid
it looks good it's well shot the cast
that I mean the cast know this these
parts inside and out front to back
they've got this nailed they've got this
completely locked down and I really like
how much of an element of Aging and and
getting older and the concerns and the
challenges and the sort of the
existential fears that come with getting
older a lot of this being funneled
through Kirk but it comes up with some
other characters as well because I mean
we've got Kirk here you know this is the
he is very much the Kirk from the TV
show but he's also he's significantly
older he has an adult kid you know he's
an admiral which means he's no longer in
command of a ship he's not gallivanting
about space anymore and the the weight
of that and the transition of that and
what does it mean to be his age what is
his life now that's kind of weighing on
him and I like how that plays that is
played here and I think it's one of the
things that we don't get as much of
anymore
because I think the the instinct mode
with most franchises these days is if
it's been a significant amount of time
since the last iteration or the last
iteration failed really hard that you
just you reboot and so like if we were
still using current franchise management
logic back in the late 70s when the
original Star Trek motion picture
happened it wouldn't have been a
continuation of a show that had been off
the air for a while it would have been a
reboot maybe same characters but whole
new cast yeah you know linking up with
it would have been like reboot Trek like
we got like we got now and wow I you
know there is value in reboots I don't
think they're an inherently a bad thing
but I think when it becomes the default
we lose some story possibilities of
characters confronting their own
mortality which is a big part of this of
this particular film if you've never
seen Wrath of Khan I am eventually
beginning two spoilers but this movies
literally as old as I am so I don't know
what else to tell you I'll still try and
avoid getting into what would be
flat-out spoilers until closer to the
begin but just like if I drop them don't
get mad at me
so we've got this cast coming back and
we've got these themes laid in about
ageing about finding your purpose or
refining your purpose or figuring all
that stuff out and there's and we've got
the perfect villain for that Ricardo
Montalban as Caan so okay first off
bringing back a character who was a
one-off villain from the TV show who we
have not seen since not even heard
mention of since feeds into the themes
that are going on here like I don't know
in the story writing process I would
love to know what happened first did
they come up with the themes they wanted
to work with and then pick a villain who
works for that or did they pick a
fill-in and then figure out what themes
work if we're gonna use this villain I
don't know which came first but they
work brilliantly together because as
Kirk is getting to a point where he's
trying to figure out what to do with his
life he's confronted with a villain who
is very certain about what he wants to
do with his life because what he wants
to do is take revenge and there's so
many good things about first of all
Ricardo montalbán scene shooing is so
often a negative term and more often
than not if an actor is said to be
chewing the scenery they're going way
over the top but sometimes way over the
top works and here over the top works
for how intelligent this guy supposed to
be and how much he knows that he's
intelligent it makes sense that he's
spouting this poetic dialogue that he's
tucking these bold declarative
statements that he is super into his own
importance and part of what I love about
this is that at the end of the day you
break this guy town he is a petty petty
little man he has this brilliant
mine this brilliant intellect but he
can't see past this one very selfish
goal of seeking revenge and which is
something that gets pointed out very
blatantly and it is just played us so
well by you know him as a character by
the characters around in the way that he
impacts everybody
he's just ah he's magnetic and also the
tension between him and Shatner as Kirk
is amazing astounding that it is as good
as it is because the two of them never
actually share a scene the closest that
come is that they're on either side of a
monitor they're never in the same
physical space at any point in this film
and yet you never doubt the anger the
history the tension and despite pulling
a character from the TV show from an
episode that I actually have still not
seen it explains just enough and then
Ricardo Montalban sells the rest of it
that it works it totally works there's
some other stuff that I think it was
good also good to me to see as more of
an adult because you've got things like
but I can't remember what they were
called or if they've been actually
properly made and named them but the
little brain worm things that burrow
into the ear it's still gonna skeet me a
little bit when I was a kid yeah did did
not like that scene particularly and not
and not enough to make you know my list
of move of movies that really freaked me
out that I did I did last month but yeah
it was so but it's interesting to see
those kind of elements brought in and
because they do feel to a certain extent
out of place in Star Trek because it is
so gruesome and it is so horrific and
that's not something you normally see in
Star Trek but that elevates the threat
of Khan because he's the kind of guy who
will bring this in to this world where
it doesn't belong
because it serves his need it serves his
revenge all the other characters are
really great some get obviously a lot
more cause to shine
Kirk is very firmly the focus in this
one I I mean he we get but we get just
the right amount of time with most of
the other cast I think honestly Scotty
gets a bit of short shrift he doesn't
get a ton to do check off gets
highlighted but you know he's not in a
way that's that's fun for him hora is
just kind of there but I mean she's
always a great presence Spock you know
McCoy has has a couple of good moments
couple of good minds a couple of the
good lightning moments I always love
McCoy as being the guy who is expecting
the absolute worst possible outcome out
of anything they are looking at whereas
Kirk ultimately Kirk's kind of an
optimist McCoy is not I love that
dynamic and that was spark he is not as
embedded in this film as I sort of
remembered him being or as I would have
expected given the direction things go
at the end but he's in it just enough
for that ending to work even if this is
the first or only Star Trek film you've
ever seen because enough is established
about him and about his relationship
with Kirk especially in the early parts
of the film and then reiterated you know
your reminder it's it's it's classic
storytelling you have you have your
setup your reminder your payoff and the
set up of the relationship between Spock
and Kirk as' is done in those early
scenes and we get little reminder
moments in about the middle and then we
have to pay off at the end and
supporting cast is pretty solid the kid
who's well I say kiddies huh I don't
want to think about how old he is now
but the the guy who plays Kirk's son
David is he's fine I mean he's just kind
of there but he he does kind of evoke
the energy that Shatner had you know
back when when it was a TV show so I
mean he works he's believable
is that Carol Marcus is a good character
she she has the the right sort of level
of strength that you kind of have to
assume anybody needs to have if they're
going to put up with Kirk for very even
a short period of time honestly
and then there's Kirstie Alley as Saavik
an interesting thing it was it threw me
off a little bit I don't know I don't
know if it's standard in like in
nautical situations nautical ranking and
terminology because that's where that's
where Star Trek takes most of its cues
from for like the positive for the
positions because you know it's captain
Admiral it's it's like if the Navy but
they kept calling her mr. Kirk kept
calling her mr. Saavik which I don't
know odd way that kind of made me smile
but like that normal or Dior is a Star
Trek that does that it's probably
standard in in like naval speak with you
know certain a certain position tart and
do a certain other position they just
use mister and whatever the last name is
regardless of gender but I don't know
kind of liked it and she's actually
really good in that part i Kirstie Alley
is has had a bit of a rollercoaster life
but when she's good she's good and she's
good in this she's she has that same
quality that Nimoy has which is that she
sells the the the removal of emotion the
the did they the logic focus of it but
manages to do it without becoming a
boring character as a result which is
always the trap with Vulcans so yeah
geez she's actually quite good as well
um it's not a perfect film I mean I
don't want to criticize anything for you
know just because it hasn't aged well I
mean there's like really crazy early
sort of CGI looking stuff I'm going on
here which you know it's fine but I
think the one thing that sort of struck
me is like oh man
and the things it what I'm about to
mention is not unique to this film but
stood out to me I think of a lot more
here than it has before
so the reliance which is the ship at the
beginning that check off is odd he's
he's the executive officer
so he's second-in-command and there's
some questions about what's down on this
planet and the captain and the executive
officer both go down without additional
security detail to check it out the the
idea of the captain leaving the ship at
all it is kind of dumb the idea of the
captain and the XO both going down at
the same time and I understand they were
not expecting to find danger but like
that's just hey there's no way that can
be that could be like I'm just even
allowed when your leader and the guy who
takes his place is on the a masseur both
leave together well and like I said this
actually happens a lot in Star Trek in
general but you know the there's for
some reason it really stood out to me
this time because like wow III they need
to update Starfleet regulations because
I mean it's funny actually Saavik brings
that up later on like no captain shall
go down into a hostile situation with a
security detail my immediate thought is
screw austell situation
he shouldn't be leaving the ship at all
and definitely not with his
second-in-command in tow regardless of
the situation that's stupid but you know
again I I sort of get where it goes I I
do wonder if the captain was necessary
and like if they had just made Chekov
the captain and had had it be him and we
didn't even have the other guy I think
that could have worked I mean maybe that
would have been promoting check off too
too far up the ranks and then it's like
well how are we ever gonna get him in
the you know on the same ship as the
rest of these folks again cuz he's
supposed to have his own command from
here I don't know but like just
restricting it to this film narrative
Lee I'm not sure we needed the other
captain and it does create that weird
moment which again if something goes on
and all of Star Trek but it just it just
really stood out to me more here if I
were to have one more complaint it's a
little bit more nitpicky
I mean I'm gonna say I'm gonna start
talking about them bought the end of the
film which is you know more spoilers
potentially if you haven't seen it
before so I feel like we're missing
literally one shot with Kahn dying so
Kahn ship has basically been wrecked he
has set the Genesis device to detonate
he knows that the blast will reach far
enough to engulf the enterprising that
the enterprise is too damaged to get out
of the range of this blast that's the
situation that he's in and you know he
has he has his line from hell's heart I
stab at thee taken from Moby Dick and
you know he he kind of starts to fade
it's not necessarily that I needed to
see him die but the shot that I want to
be in there because you know they
because of what Spock does ultimately
sacrificing his life to do the work to
get the the warp engine going again so
that the ship can safely get away at the
distance it needs to get you know
obviously Khan's ship hasn't blown up by
the time the enterprise goes there's
like I don't know a second couple
seconds I just wanted one shot of from
Khan's view can't see his monitor the
enterprise goes into warp cut back to
his face and just watch it fall and then
it blows up to me there's something
about because that shot isn't there it
almost kind of gives him a victory at
least as far as he's concerned because
it seems to imply that he dies before
they get out which means he dies
thinking he won and I kind of would
rather he got taken down that
more pay because he's such a
self-important prick that I think he
kind of deserved it I don't think he
deserved to die believing that he had a
victory but again that's that's minor
and and so like basically my only two
complaints are our minor or something
that is an intrinsic problem with this
franchise so yeah this is really good
one of these days I am gonna rank the
Star Wars not the stars the Star Trek
films I have I have a couple other ones
that I haven't seen a long time that I
need to revisit but I don't know where I
would have put this before but I think
this is going to put it higher than it
was initially I think before I mean
nostalgic Lee I it may not take the top
spot from some other stuff but if this
might put it above six because like for
me like III I always kind of preferred
undiscovered country to this one and add
that honestly might just be because I
saw undiscovered country in the theatre
and so you know I have more of an
attachment to that then again I saw I
saw it v Star Trek in the theater too
but I don't have a nostalgia for that so
I don't know but I like this is really
good
I get why so many Trek fans say that
this is their favorite Trek film I get
it
not sure it's mine but and it's good and
it's it is tense and it without like a
ton of like real action scenes
it feels intense and it feels you know
that clash
you don't need wall-to-wall action to
still get that this film proves it so
Star Trek to Wrath of Khan
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's a
whole bunch of buttons and links down
there including a link to my patreon if
you are feeling so generous and want to
help things out but you know what if you
don't don't worry about it there's other
links to check out you don't have to
look at any of them
you don't want coz at the end of the day
you are the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is insured
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]